I can't hear you,
man.
How's everyone doing?
Ah,
so I let you in on a secret for 40 years,
40 years.
I've been trying to learn how to dance.
Every teacher I hired quit on me,
so I decided to hire the best in the war.
So everyone with loud,
thunderous applause.
Please welcome my new dance teacher Madre.
They should minute
[inaudible]
dearly.
Uh,
these two need no introduction.
but you know,
let me just remind you for some of those who are a bit younger than I am.
Okay.
So Marjorie is clearly one of the most popular leading at press in Indian
cinema,
known for her powerful performances and amazing dance skills that you just saw.
She voted audience in classic films like Dayjah,
Ramla Con,
uh,
sergeant [inaudible].
They have dust and many,
many more six film theater awards,
grace,
her mantle piece at the house.
Okay.
And that's out of a 16 record nomination that she got in film pedal boards.
And that's just the film fair award.
So,
okay,
let me just read a list of awards.
She has one pretty much anything that you can win in Indian cinema.
Marjorie has one them and that's why I need the paper because I won't be able to
remember those.
Okay.
So [inaudible] is one [inaudible] three award platinum diva award screen award,
woke Bali view beauty legend award,
right guys,
z scenario ward.
Just to name a few.
And to top it all off,
she was awarded the Button Shri one of the highest civilian honors by the
government of India in 2000 a day.
Thank you.
She's also a UNICEF goodwill ambassador and her husband is an accomplished
cardiothoracic surgeon,
Dr Three Romney Ne.
Okay.
Now Rom is a product of some of the top cardiac schools in the country,
Washington University and Ucla and practiced for over a decade before moving to
India with Marjorie and they're two lovely sons.
Okay.
Do
gather this doctor dance with Maddrey,
an initiative to,
uh,
help teach everyone in the world about dance and wants to expand it to include
music,
acting and medicine.
I've known both of them for a bit and there is one thing for which they do not
give out an award,
but if they did RAAM in Matraville vinet hands down every year of their lives.
And that one thing is humility.
They both have hearts of gold and they have filled their lives with family love,
selflessness and yes,
humility.
Martha Vietnam.
It's a joy to welcome you to the Google stage.
[inaudible]
thank you very much.
I mean it's our pleasure to be here and um,
you know,
Amit and I spend a bit of time together last summer,
which he may or may not have told you about.
We did a a six day trek in the dock and we started about 9,000 feet when all the
way to 17,000,
500 feet.
And this was the sort of track that humbles any one of us.
And this guy was like iron man,
you know,
he came in,
flew in at the last minute on Dymocks and uh,
the rest of us,
we're all having our vasal dilation headaches.
And you know,
I mean,
you can imagine walking between 10 and 15 miles a day at that altitude.
It really tests you.
And the bottom line is having friends like him is what matters in anyone's
lifetime.
And that's what makes it full.
And so it's,
it's an absolute pleasure to be here amongst friends and family and,
uh,
we,
we were really looking forward to that.
Thank you ram for the kind words.
Okay.
Now you all guys be nice to me in the future.
All right.
So mothery uh,
when you started on the Bollywood scene,
uh,
you are known for your dance.
Um,
how long have you been dancing?
Well,
been dancing ever since I was three years old.
I'm classically trained,
uh,
I've learned Cuttack that's a north Indian style of classical dancing.
Yes.
Ooh,
I love that style.
I really loved that style because I feel once you learned,
you can do any style in the world.
And which I have done through my movies.
Um,
I'm a very,
very passionate actress.
Uh,
it's my first love acting,
but dance has always been my passion.
I've grown up dancing.
So,
uh,
even when I did my films,
I tried to do some extra,
you know,
that add a little bit of extra with me and zero g,
uh,
as,
the choreographer.
He has everybody knows about her.
Uh,
we formed a lovely team and,
uh,
we worked so well together because we were both passionate about dancing and we
wanted to take Indian film dancing to a different level,
you know?
And that's what our,
um,
uh,
you know,
Google used to be every time we did a song together.
Awesome.
Um,
what,
what drew you to dance?
Was it instant when you were like three years old?
I'm at,
this is what I want to do.
It came,
I don't know,
to me it came naturally.
Um,
I just was attracted to dance and,
um,
I think,
you know,
it's,
it's everything to me is everything because,
um,
it keeps you fit.
It makes you feel good.
It,
you know,
it makes your soul feel good.
And,
uh,
it's just,
it's,
um,
it's a beautiful way to express
and there are lots of parents in the audience here who are probably putting
their kids in dance school right now.
Um,
what advice would both of you have for those parents here?
Well,
I would say,
uh,
Gloria computers
and Google as Don's with Marguerite is my a website,
then you can go on that.
You can take a look.
There are so many different styles.
We are teaching a on this site and a,
I think what is important is to see what your kid takes to like your child has
to take to a certain style of dancing and they will just know it within their
souls that,
you know,
this is what I wanted,
what that is what I want to do and let them follow their heart because you know,
if they do something they love,
they'll really,
really give it their all.
And um,
all the styles are they under one roof on a dance with mothery.
So I would first like them to try it out and see and select which dance they
would like to learn.
They can learn it on the website where they can go to a school in London.
I think to add one thing to that dance,
to me it's about happiness,
confidence and health and what did epitomizes is a holistic way to kind of take
care of yourself.
It becomes a metaphor for life in some regards.
So when we put this project together,
quite an interesting journey in that,
um,
as some of you know,
I grew up here and um,
I had done some software entrepreneur work at the age of 14 and had a company
and my Indian parents said,
you either become a doctor,
engineer or we won't pay for it.
Does that sound familiar to you guys?
Yes.
Yeah.
And so,
so the thing was I,
being the dutiful son became a doctor and I became a heart surgeon and I really
loved my career.
Very rewarding.
Took care of some amazing people in very difficult times.
But my problem was I couldn't scale it.
And no matter how hard I worked,
three to 500 patients per year.
And the issue for me was that there's 7 billion people on the planet.
So the journey I made was that if I could take my original skills combined with
her media talent and then amalgamate them with brick and mortar,
we could change the way people think about medicine.
And we moved to India in 2011 kind of a bold thing.
You can imagine my parents' face.
What are you doing?
You are the head of a hospital,
you are a partner in a group.
You've been practicing for 10 years and you do three to 500 cases a year and
you're just abandoning all that to go and start a startup or something like
that.
I don't know.
It's a journey many of you might have made or will make at some point in your
life,
but daunting.
Nevertheless.
So then during the course I was building out the healthcare constructs and one
day she said to me that,
you know,
culture as we know it is changing.
And I learned dance and acting because I loved it.
It was passionate.
And what ended up happening was now in the cinemas and other things,
it's a lot of commercialism.
She's like,
if I could teach this,
I could change the way people think.
And I'm like,
well,
you were facing the same problems that I am,
that we can't scale it.
So what if we put a team on this and scaled it?
And what ended up happening was,
uh,
three months of rapid prototyping and engineering launched in 2013.
Didn't know if it would work.
And what we ended up finding out is that people could learn remotely and they
could extend their level and move forward.
So the idea is to build a global village for culture where everyone is equal.
And you know,
I think the last thought is genius exists in everyone.
The standardized test don't examine it.
And the problem is there's a lot of people on the planet who don't have the
opportunities that we do.
And so the idea is if you can take this out to them and find them and nurture
that kernel of genius into a full grown plan,
you've will change the way people think and how things happen.
So her love of dance kind of spurned this and it became a platform and it grew.
And so I'll,
I'll show you some of that later.
Yeah,
great.
Thank you rob.
That's great.
As you said,
you were raised here and I know for a fact that before you met Madre,
you did not follow in the cinema very much.
Okay.
So what happened dude,
when someone mentioned mothery for the first time,
we do run to your computer and Google her.
That's a good way to set it up there.
I uh,
you know,
I might've,
I don't know.
I,
I the the thing is my folks are from Mumbai and I could only speak for it.
I didn't speak in the end.
So we hadn't grown up watching Hindi cinema.
And the other thing was I was at Ucla and so we took care of the lot of the
Hollywood industry and I'll be very candid with you that the industry there is
completely crazy.
I mean,
the types of people you meet,
I'm like,
the last thing I want to do is see someone in the industry.
But then I met her brother and he was phenomenal and very down to earth,
very grounded and kind of fit our sort of overall mindset and agreed to meet
her.
And I think I probably might've googled her back then.
Right?
Yeah.
Hooters.
He just doesn't want to admit it.
Oh No,
I'm,
I'm giving them the whole,
we all know how it works.
That's okay.
Yeah.
The rest is history.
There you have it.
So my three,
how was it leaving Mumbai Bollywood and coming here and living in Denver rather
cold compared to Mumbai for over a decade.
How was it for you?
Yeah,
you know,
and,
and Mumbai,
it's hot,
hotter and hottest.
Last time I saw snow and cold and fall and,
you know,
all the four seasons and it was beautiful.
But I mean,
then what is a beautiful place to live for anyone you walk out and everything
that I'd never found in Mumbai,
I gotten Denver because,
um,
you know,
just the,
it was pleasing to the eyes that the air is so beautiful and,
uh,
the mountains all around a very beautiful place.
Um,
you know,
in life,
everybody has dreams,
right?
You have goals,
you have dreams.
And having a family,
having kids was a big part of my dream,
not just my profession and being an actress and or everything else.
But for me,
this was a big,
big deal for me because I grew up in a big family.
Uh,
we have four siblings.
And,
uh,
so for me,
having kids was,
um,
you know,
very,
very important,
um,
having a husband and a home and that's,
that's was a big part of my dream.
Um,
of course I wanted to 12 children at one point when I was little bad,
but after I had to,
I was like,
yeah,
this is good enough.
Um,
but it's really,
I mean,
that's why I enjoyed myself.
I,
I kind of throw myself into everything I do.
Um,
whether it was looking after my kids or my home or,
uh,
you know,
living their live,
going out shopping it,
it gave me a sense of freedom because in Mumbai,
if I go shopping and they're like 10 people around me,
you know,
um,
and,
uh,
I was never left alone.
Basically,
I remember the first time I went out just to grocery shop,
I had to take my car and go in.
My heart was just like thumping.
It was like boom,
boom,
boom.
As if I'm trying to do something that I've never done before and um,
but it,
it just freed me to give a,
give a sense of freedom.
And for me,
life is not all about just my profession or just acting or just dancing.
It's as experiencing every day,
you know,
the different kinds of things you have to go through the situations and how you
deal with them.
And uh,
the life lessons,
you know,
I love to live my life basically.
And so that's what was most attractive about it.
Wonderful.
That's so wonderful.
Yes.
We're talking about movies you have done like 70 plus movies.
How many?
78 [inaudible] 78 less movies.
Yes.
It's been a paper at one for you.
Um,
you know,
everybody asks me that,
but it's a very cliched answer.
People might say,
Oh,
you're very diplomatic.
But it's true because every movie we do,
there's a little bit of me in the movie.
Um,
but if you like put a gun to my head and said no,
you have to say one movie.
Oh,
but you have really enjoyed I would say,
um,
I enjoyed doing that movie because we were a lot of actors together at every
point in the movie.
12 of us,
six of us.
And we really had fun making the movie.
Also talked about all the values that I believe in,
you know,
a family and uh,
like uh,
uh,
you know,
extended family and everybody living together in peace and harmony and all that.
And it will be a mob guy had gone obviously.
Right.
Okay.
Alright.
So after that question here,
the two part question
two part question,
part one is there Edward Beads on movie night at the home.
When you put a modern movie and all of you watch it,
number two,
when you do do that or when your kids do watch Ahmad re movie,
how judgmental are they?
About
four minutes.
I just tell you one incident,
I as,
as I was leaving home,
my kids were watching cable and one of my movies was on Goya and they were like
in a sitting in front of the,
and I'm,
yeah,
I'm out of here.
I'm leaving.
So I left and I came back in the evening and on the computer,
on one of my kid's computer,
there was little note hanging there,
which said,
mom.
And I'm like,
what's this?
So I just picked it up and it was deal,
mom,
why are you acting so funny?
And coya
orange.
So for them it's like,
you know,
uh,
it varies.
Uh,
the reaction varies.
And I remember in glove gang,
there was this one shot where I raise my hand and I'm like the big boss kind of,
and I'm doing this and my kid's side and just freaked out.
And they would do doing variations of that little walking
that.
So nobody takes me seriously,
me and my family.
That's what I'm trying to say.
I think the other comment to make is we don't wear stars on our shoulders.
And when we go home,
all of that turns off.
In fact,
all of the trophies you were talking about are all in the office.
Um,
we don't allow him at home.
And you know,
we,
we don't watch her films.
I mean,
I've only seen like a handful since we've been married,
mainly because of the Indian Ocean.
Now I speak in the,
but the,
the issue is,
um,
uh,
I think it's about being grounded and not getting caught up in your careers.
I mean,
whether it's a heart surgeon or an actress or anything else that's just a job.
You're passionate about what you do,
but it's the holistic kind of balance that you strike in your life.
And just remember that,
you know,
you're very fortunate in every,
every one of us is in this room.
And there's a lot of people who don't have that.
And so the idea is to think of others when you do stuff and to do it for those
reasons rather than for yourself.
Although we are very passionate about what we do,
regardless of what it is.
Um,
but I would say the movie nights are generally the transformers or,
or something like the hat with the place.
And I'm just hanging out and having some fun.
So how's the move to India bead?
Ah,
I think
it's been amazing.
I mean India has changed dramatically.
I,
I my inlaws I'm sorry,
my,
my family came from the other and I'm in Mumbai if you guys have been to Mumbai
at all and I would go back there every summer to,
uh,
hang out with my grandma and GRANDPA.
And uh,
so I,
I'd been there and seen it change over 40 years.
If you go there now,
not just Mumbai,
Delhi,
Bangalore,
any of these cities,
it's come in such a direction.
And I,
I don't know if you call it forward,
sideways,
upside down and whatever,
but I mean it's becoming a western culture very quickly and they have some
significant issues that grapple with and yet the culture is so beautiful.
And you know,
I call him one by my,
my Manhattan of sorts because you can get food anytime of day.
The,
uh,
people are very warm and there are different struggles.
I mean traffic is the same everywhere I found out today.
And it was the same.
It was the same in La and same in Mumbai and whatnot,
just very Asians on the theme.
But I think overall it's been an amazing experience.
And,
um,
I would recommend if you guys get some time,
I mean a lot of you guys I see in the audience are from India originally and so
you understand it,
but I think it's so rapidly changing.
And I,
I mean this new prime minister and whatnot is bringing us in a direction which
is unfathomable.
And even in the last 10 years,
the number of advances,
um,
are amazing.
Cool.
So that's great.
Now you move back to India and the first question my daughter had for me was,
does she go to subdue Mandy herself?
Now?
Uh,
no.
I think it's back to square one where I have to pick and choose where I can be
away.
I can go,
but I do try,
you know,
because,
um,
after living in Denver and after being so independent,
when you go back and everything is a little different then because when you live
there,
you take everything for granted,
you know,
oh my mate is going to go and get this,
that and that.
But now when you lived by yourself,
I'm done everything.
It's like I want to go,
but how do I do it?
So then I'll wear my hat or my big goal glares or something like that and I
feel,
oh,
this is the proper disguise.
Nobody's going to look at me and while you're buying,
you know,
your veggies or whatever,
and then somebody comes in with us.
I haven't heard of half these,
I failed again.
But,
um,
but yes,
I do try to do that.
Um,
it's,
it's a little limited,
but I still try,
I would say the truth is this,
right?
Okay.
There's not many places she can go with me.
On the other hand,
I'll,
I'll go by train,
I'll go by bus and my people will say,
no,
you can't do that.
And it never really bothered me.
Right.
I grew up in the US.
The hardest part for me is that I can't change a light bulb without someone
saying,
no,
you got to call this person or do this.
I'm like,
really?
Come on.
I grew up in the u s we did everything for ourselves.
And so it's been that way.
A little bit of a change.
But for her,
I mean in the u s she would put together the Ikea furniture and the other stuff
we got and she loves that.
Yeah,
exactly.
And from what little,
I know he was much better at it then Rom.
Okay.
Not True.
So let's talk about dance with my buddy Tom.
You're trying to build a community of artists,
of dancers,
people who love dancing,
people who want to learn dancing there.
Did the idea come from,
where do you want to take it?
Um,
so you know,
the,
the thing is,
I kind of hinted at this earlier,
every single one of us has a little genius in him,
right?
And it just dawned on us that what if Pablo Picasso never got his pencil or pen
or paintbrush?
What if Marie Curie never got an opportunity to go and learn?
And what if Einstein never had an opportunity to write this thesis and then
think how many people in the world never have that opportunity?
And so for me,
I started out with this health construct to take good evidence based medicine to
everyone on the planet.
Because what I saw was that there were a lot of people who weren't getting the
opportunities that all of us have in this room and in the u s and even in the u
s for that matter.
When I was practicing several years ago,
38 million people never had insurance.
And the idea is that medicine is one of those things that everyone should have.
But I,
it went further than that.
And what it became was a platform where we could experiment and we could teach
people in a fun and social manners.
So this is one of those things where if you gamify learning,
you can change the way people learn.
I remember learning when I was growing up that it was all rote memorization,
right?
You must learn this and then throw it up on the test and you will do well.
But my,
my feeling is that that really leaves out the bell curve,
right?
The ends of it.
And so what we've done is tried to make it fun and social at the same time.
We've taken dance in particular and used it to stay fit.
So I put a fitness band on her and in 15 minutes she,
her heart rate sustain was one 32 one 60 and her a caloric burn was 400
calories.
So we put that on our youtube channel.
Just wanted to put that plug in there,
add.
We had like 175 hours of viewing per month became like our number one,
you know,
most viewed thing.
And so when we found is people were learning certainly,
but they were using dance as a means to work out.
And if you think about it,
what would you rather do?
Be on a treadmill,
you know,
looking at a TV or whatever,
or have some beautiful woman in front of you,
taking you through the moves and losing calories in 15 minutes.
And then what we did was we knit that together with a social network and a
marketplace.
So now when these people learn,
they're not just learning,
but they're creating video resumes and what they're doing is essentially
becoming marketable.
So what we're doing is we're discovering talent from all over the planet,
not just from,
you know,
one area.
I would love to cue that one video if we have it on the edge of naturally piece.
All right guys,
can we kill the video please?
I think this tells a story very nicely.
So all in all,
it became a passion play in that what could we do to change people's lives?
And dance was really the tip of the iceberg because if you take this and build
it out to the other verticals,
it becomes incredibly even.
So the video,
this is an aboriginal.
So before we actually start the lesson,
I want you to get familiar with some of the hand would raise
your right hand with the Lotus.
And the other hand is like a dia hand.
One,
two,
three.
So you're curling your hands.
A pizza style.
It doesn't it.
Cool.
Okay.
So this is the sign or the hook or the signature stamp.
God separate
Gada
speaking of bands,
Ram,
could you dad's before he met her?
Yeah,
I could cut a rug,
but not like after.
I mean some of the parties we've gone to in some of the things she's taught me,
it's another world,
you know.
And Are you any better now?
I would say so.
Can you answer that?
Yeah.
I mean
we wouldn't have this body and um,
you know,
they were like,
oh,
you have to dance.
This is doctor Neha.
You go to Dan's,
Dan's and it would produce insisting and those Riddick and those shadow can
Florida and everyone.
And you know,
uh,
yeah,
who said that?
All of the them.
And um,
I had to grab him and say,
Oh,
you go to dad's on the floor.
And he was like,
Oh my God,
I'm like,
we were shooting for all this.
And I think he's picked up a lot.
It's just watching and he was so good on the floor that Pharaoh came up to me
and says,
he's going to be my next dance bar there now.
Yeah.
So yeah,
I mean he's,
he's,
you know,
he's free of spirit and he loves to learn and he is very observant and I know of
you were doing classes or whatever,
by the way.
He's also done one of the classes where,
um,
it's called dance for the non dancers.
So,
okay.
So his trading started there.
I will take that.
Yeah.
And,
and I think you should try it.
Yes.
Okay.
I think it's infectious.
You know what I mean?
You,
you see these people and it's just as I say,
poetry in motion or fluid and it really kind of drives you after awhile.
I mean,
there's a lot of things that do,
but there's different types of art.
This is one of those things that really makes it happiness.
Cool.
So in a minute I'm going to open it up to the audience for questions.
If you have a question for a Maddrey and Ram,
please get to one of these mics.
Uh,
you know,
the Tgi of routine.
Um,
and I'm going to make just one comment,
two comments.
Actually.
The one is,
it's free and our goal is to keep it free forever so that there's absolutely no,
you know,
impediments or obstacles to the end user.
The second is all of the greatest artists are coming on the platform,
whether it's BG,
Hamachi,
Saroj,
con Terrence remo,
um,
and a host of Jelic and other choreographers.
The idea is to create one place where everyone can go and feel free to add and
subtract and bring everyone together.
And the idea was literally global village for Culture,
right?
And so that's the idea behind it.
Hmm.
Okay.
Before I open it up,
one question.
What's that one piece of technology that you guys can't live with that
miles,
we cannot live without technology.
There has to be a gadget for everything in the house,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
but that's like,
I love all my children.
Answer.
Right.
That's
what a guy's supposed to give us an answer.
Okay.
Now someone put a gun to your head and said,
what's the one piece of technology?
My goodness.
Yes.
Iphone.
Easily the,
yeah.
All right.
Hang on.
I'm going to show you some love.
I've got my android
and,
and actually,
yeah,
I'll just tell you one other thing.
I've got dance with mothery on it.
It actually runs better than my iPhone,
so try it.
Oh,
that's so awesome.
Now
we asked people who couldn't get in today,
uh,
to submit a bunch of questions for you and let me start asking some of those
questions that people have submitted for you.
Now,
many of us who came to the u s as adults have found the social anonymity of not
being known by anybody.
Something to adjust to.
In your case,
the feeling must have been far greater.
Did you welcome that change?
If not,
how did you deal with it?
Yeah,
it was a welcome change.
Uh,
because then you're like famous or you're a celebrity in India.
There's not much you can do.
You know,
and the way I worked,
um,
for me,
life was just,
you know,
from one studio to another to another to another.
And I really didn't get to live life normally,
you know,
like how everybody lives.
They go out with their friends,
the college friends.
And I started very early.
I started when I was 16,
so I missed out on all that.
And uh,
not that I'm complaining,
but,
but that's,
that's the life I knew.
And when I moved to Denver,
it was like I said,
you know,
freedom for me because suddenly I was free to do anything that I wanted to.
I could go to the grocery shop,
I didn't have to,
you know,
dress up or do anything.
I could just go the way I was and a,
I could get grocery,
I could take my kids out,
go to the park,
just enjoy everything.
And um,
another part of it is when I met Rom,
um,
he was into adventure sports and he used to do all kinds of crazy stuff and
which had no done in my life.
I'm a very careful person and you know,
a very protected,
and I'm just,
I just knew that I was,
you know,
an actress and I went from one studio to another and I danced and I sang and I
acted and everything.
But this was like freedom.
I was outdoors the first day after we met,
he said,
um,
let's go mountain biking.
And I had not ridden a bike in 20 years.
I had done it when I was little and I had not.
And I thought mountain biking is this,
taking a bike and going on a mountain.
Right.
How hard can that be?
And when I went with him,
it was like,
Whoa,
I was coming down like rocky thing.
Then I was like,
did I just do that?
And that was like,
at some point I was like,
you know,
I don't think I can do this and say why.
And I said,
oh,
because I haven't done this in 20 years.
So he's like,
you cannot mountain bike as it.
No.
So there was some portions made to carry my bike and we just walked across and
did all that.
But it just gave me a sense of freedom.
Just showed me another,
you know,
life all together and I really,
really enjoyed every moment of it.
That's,
that's so joyful.
Let's take the first question.
Uh,
please.
Hello.
Hello doctor.
Hi.
How are you?
First compliment first.
Mothery you are great.
Amazing gift to this universe.
It's,
it's,
it's really,
really amazing.
And here I was not listening anything.
I was just staring you because this is the first time I'm seeing you in person.
Thank you.
I have two questions,
one to moderate and one to Dr [inaudible].
I'm Audrey.
How does it feel like being mothery?
Like do you see like something special or like it's kind of God give Troy I
know.
Let's put it this way that you guys make me feel special.
Okay.
Yeah,
there's a lot of love around me and I know everybody's looking at me very
lovingly and it makes me feel special.
It makes me feel special.
But I don't know.
I,
I'm,
I'm just a very happy person.
I,
I'm very positive in life and,
uh,
whenever I look at something,
I see life,
you know,
like the glass half full,
not half empty.
So I just enjoy every moment in my life.
And um,
I don't think too much about that.
I don't think about the fact that I'm Marjorie or you know,
whatever.
I'm just a person and,
um,
you know,
who loves doing things and I want to share that with my fans now because I love
dancing so much.
I want to share that with them.
And so,
um,
you know,
that's how I look at it.
Okay.
What's,
what's the one thing you want to give it to the world other than dancing?
Um,
I think joy,
happiness,
um,
just um,
feel good about themselves.
That's something I would really love to give back.
Okay.
Thanks.
A question to Dr Nina is,
um,
what was your first reaction when you met mothery?
Um,
you know,
I don't know what to say.
It's,
I,
I didn't know who she was.
He was speechless.
Yeah.
That
this
man will never learn.
I've tried teaching.
Okay.
I've been married long enough.
It probably doesn't matter,
but I make him speechless.
What,
no,
but,
um,
I mean,
what,
what you find,
so there,
there's a couple of points.
The first is,
um,
I grew up in La.
I was surrounded by the industry,
you know,
and,
and so what you found is they put their pants on one leg at a time just like
everyone else.
And the issue is that,
um,
the,
the connect was that we didn't treat it there are different regardless of what
our stature was,
what we did.
And the one thing I loved about her was that she's down to earth and very,
very straightforward and focused and no nonsense.
Um,
and that's not always the case in the filming line.
And I'll tell you that I think you can answer that.
And so we are kind of the unfill me people,
you know,
and that we're real and we like to stay that way.
And you won't see us going out and doing crazy stuff.
I mean,
it's fun once in a while,
but the bottom line is that it has to be a balance.
You know,
so the answer is,
um,
she was real,
that that was what mattered to me and certainly with my career and her career.
The other comment someone had asked,
I think was the anonymity factor,
right?
She's the one person who's been everywhere and yet been nowhere.
And what I mean by that is they close the Eiffel Tower for one of our shoots and
imagine that the Eiffel Tower,
the gendarmes,
everything else,
they went to a glacier in Alaska,
had multiple chopper setups and shooting for a movie called Paccar.
And yet for these guys,
it's a matter of getting in,
getting in hair and makeup,
putting on your clothes and jetting out.
So,
you know,
in the time we've been married,
the one kind of gift was that we could go and do things normally and the u s
kind of afforded that in that she could actually go out and drive to whole foods
or whatever and buy groceries,
which,
you know,
that doesn't sound like a lot of sounds like a chore to most people.
But for someone like this,
it's,
it's like freedom.
Yeah,
I can imagine.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I really want to thank Google for organizing this.
Thank you.
That's big.
The next question.
Hello again guys.
So a mother,
you when at what point in your career did you realize maybe where you're
reflecting at some point that you had made it because there are a lot of men and
women in India and everyone in the world who want to be where you are at.
When did you feel yes,
I've done it.
Um,
you know,
um,
my film was released in [inaudible] 89 and I remember I was not in India when it
released.
Um,
I was here in the U S and I was in Washington know Chicago.
I think because my sister was getting married and my agent at that point,
uh,
had called me and he said,
um,
who don't get Hindou Hindou get here
and I know how to hit film.
So for me it was like,
oh good,
I have a hit vote now.
I,
it's a hit.
It's like success.
And uh,
so I was very happy about that,
but I had never faced a recognition before when I was working on once in a while
maybe.
But I landed at the airport and it was these two little kids,
you know,
who come and kind of wipe your car sometimes and they're like,
uh,
so they were looking at me and a 71 of them says,
I knew the Eagleton good.
And I'm like,
I said,
yeah,
it's just give me,
have an autograph.
And I was so thrilled,
you know,
saying anything,
an autograph.
And somebody recognized me and I signed my name and Arrow model addiction,
then I gave it to him and he don't do,
the other guy says [inaudible].
Yeah.
So yeah,
that was the first time I thought,
oh my goodness,
I made it.
Thank you.
All right,
let's take the next question over there.
Hi,
my name is [inaudible].
Hello.
First of all,
I still feel I'm dreaming.
I cannot believe that you are watching me right now.
So I have two questions.
The first is about dance with Monterey.
I've never danced in my entire life and it's probably because of that inhibition
that you were talking about and that has grown so much that I'm not at all
comfortable dancing.
So how would dance with Marjorie health and what advice do you have for people
like me was dance with modular is something you can do in your own time,
in your own space.
You could when you own room in front of your computer that nobody's watching
you,
you know,
and it's just the teacher in front of you and you and I think somewhere it'll
help you get all your inhibitions because nobody's watching you do that.
And we dance with modular.
You can rewind it 20,000 times and see it again and again and again,
which a school doesn't afford you because once you go there,
the classes just for one hour you come home and you have to basically work where
your memory,
you know,
whenever your memory is good,
that's what you will remember.
But with this you can practice in your own time and your own space and you can,
every little lesson is split into 15 second does,
you know?
So they will teach you step by step every little thing and I think it'll be
easier to learn that way.
Let's take the next question over there.
I'm keeping time.
I want lots of people ask.
Great.
All right.
Thank you.
I hope that answers you.
Yes,
thank you.
Hi Marjorie,
you've got an enigmatic spider,
a fantastic dance for and definitely a fabulous artist.
I mean we're all crazed here.
My question to his friend,
Dana is you are walking down the aisle with the heartthrob of India,
right?
All the men.
I mean,
how many letters and emails did you get from all the men from India grabbing
this lady?
I,
you know,
I don't remember much of that.
It was my chief resident year at Ucla in general surgery and,
um,
we didn't get a lot of sleep.
Um,
fortunately there was a good PR core there and,
uh,
they would protect me.
But once in a while on rounds,
someone would surprise you and say,
Hey,
are you this person or that person?
And that was new for me.
And so I,
I didn't really live in that.
I mean,
we were kind of insulated our agents and everyone
do.
You didn't know what he was getting into
in short.
That's,
that's good.
Uh,
mixed question.
I'm sorry.
I'll have to make that the last question over there.
Which,
uh,
hi Aparna biggest bunker now.
Um,
which,
um,
who among the following are the best is the best dancer according to a critic
Roshan be
someone can see Govinda the Prabu diva.
Oh my God.
Huh.
Yeah.
The thing is that all these guys are such good dancers,
but of course if you take the whole package,
I would say no,
not in that sense.
Um,
what,
yeah,
I know.
Um,
if you dig the hole,
uh,
functionality and everything,
I think that's a better word.
A,
it'll be to take Russian because I think,
yeah,
cause when he dances it's like he's just mesmerized as you,
I would say probably deva by a long stretch.
He's like on fire.
He has no bones,
literally no bones.
The guy can twist and do any.
Yeah,
I remember doing case the restaurant.
So that was a quite a duff song.
Uh,
so I tell you a story,
you know,
Rahm and I were hiking for six days in the dark and six days or a long time.
Periodically we'll get bored and whenever I got bored I made rom sing one of
those Hindi songs so far.
Okay.
And with Roms?
Hindi,
I would be entertained for hours.
So Ron,
would you please do us the honor.
Oh Hey.
And VR going egg dough team for you.
Okay.
All right,
you guys.
Let's give Rom.
I Dunno.
What are we singing?
Whatever you like.
One of her songs
never fails to put me on the spot here last time.
Egg Blue.
Fine.
I really,
you know,
I need like a karaoke and all the other stuff.
Oh,
we can give,
you
didn't get
the top hot says no,
we're not up there.
Hey.
Hi
Jen Vaughn to sat back.
Not this together.
Oh,
hey guys.
Join me in thanking Modrian Rom for gracing us.
I'd Google today.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
All of you have an absolute pleasure.
Yeah.